♪♪
>>> SINGER LISA MARIE PRESLEY'S
CAUSE OF DEATH JUST REVEALED.
THE 54-YEAR-OLD DIED FROM
COMPLICATIONS FROM A PRIOR
WEIGHT LOSS SURGERY.
THE REPORT SAYS IT WAS, QUOTE, A
SMOUL BOWEL OBSTRUCTION CAUSED
BY SCAR TISSUE THAT DEVELOPED
AFTER A PREVIOUS BARIATRIC
SURGERY YEARS AGO.
THE MANNER OF DEATH IS NATURAL.
JOINING US NOW IS CNN CHIEF
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT DR. SANJAY
GUPTA.
INTERESTED IN WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THIS.
HEARING OF SOMEONE DYING OF
OBSTRUCTION IN THE SMALL
INTESTINE, BUT THIS WAS
APPARENTLY A SIDE EFFECT OF THIS
KIND OF WEIGHT LOSS SURGERY?
>> RIGHT.
PARTS OF THIS STORY MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE, AND PARTS ARE A LITTLE
BIT MORE UNUSUAL.
WHAT THEY ARE DESCRIBING WHEN
THEY SAY THAT THERE WAS A
PREVIOUS OPERATION THAT LED TO
THIS, ANYTIME SOMEONE HAS AN
OPERATION ON THE ABDOMEN, INSIDE
THE BELLY, YOU CAN DEVELOP SCAR
TISSUE.
IT'S CALLED ADHESIONENS.
THINK OF IT LIKE SPIDERWEBS THAT
DEVELOP AND THEY CAN CONSTRICT
PARTS OF THE INTESTINES.
THIS TAKES PLACE OVER TIME.
HER PREVIOUS OPERATION WAS YEARS
AGO.
OVER TIME, IT MAY ACTUALLY
COMPRESS PARTS OF THE INTESTINE
TO THE POINT THEY ABOUT BECOME
OBSTRUCTED, STRANGELATED.
THEY ARE BLOCKED, ESSENTIALLY.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING FOOD THROUGH
AND THERE IS NOT ENOUGH BLOOD
THROW.
THAT HAPPENS.
WE KNOW THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN AND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE WITH OFF AND ON
PAIN FOR SOME TIME.
WHAT IS UNUSUAL, THOUGH, IS IT
SOUNDS LIKE MAYBE SHE HAD PAIN
OFF AND ON, BUT THE MORNING OF
SHE WAS COMPLAINING OF SOME PAIN
AND THEN WAS FOUND UNRESPONSIVE
AT HER HOME, TAKEN TO THE
HOSPITAL WHERE SHE SUBSEQUENTLY
DIED.
THAT WAS A VERY RAPID TIME
COURSE.
THAT'S A BIT UNUSUAL.
USUALLY, IF SOMEONE IS IN THE
HOSPITAL WITH THIS SORT OF
THING, THEY CAN EVEN GO BACK IN
AND OPERATE, DO SOMETHING TO
RELIEVE THAT BLOCKAGE, BUT SHE
HAD PROGRESSED SO FAR, SOUNDS
LIKE, BY THE TIME SHE GOT TO THE
HOSPITAL THAT SHE PASSED AWAY.
SO IT CAN HAPPEN, BUT THESE
BLOCKAGES AS WITH RESULT OF SCAR
TISSUE, BUT THE IDEA THAT THEY
LEAD TO DEATH, ESPECIALLY THAT
QUICKLY, WAS MORE UNUSUAL.
IT'S REALLY SAD, THE SITUATION
THAT UNFOLDED THERE.
>> THE REPORT ALSO LISTED
THERAPEUTIC AND NOT DANGEROUS
LEVELS OF OXYCONTIN.
CAN MEDICATIONS LIKE THAT PLAY A
ROLE IN SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I
THINK WHEN SOMEONE DIES QUICKLY,
YOU THINK DID A MEDICATION LEAD
TO THAT, DID IT INTERFERE WITH
THEIR ACT TO BREATHE ON THEIR
OWN.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE HERE, SOUNDS
LIKE FROM THE REPORT.
TWO WAYS IT MIGHT CONTRIBUTE
THOUGH.
ONE IS THAT WHAT I JUST
DESCRIBED EARLIER COULD BE
PAINFUL.
AND OPIOIDS, OTHER MEDICATIONS
CAN MASK THAT PAIN.
SOMEONE MAY GO TO THE HOSPITAL A
LITTLE BIT LATER AS A RESULT.
THE SECOND THING IS, OPIOIDS CAN
ALSO FURTHER SLOW DOWN YOUR
INTESTINES.
SO A BLOCKAGE THAT WAS ALREADY